- Hi guys, this is Heinrich
from from Firm Learning.
I hope you all are doing great.
Today I'm talking about one thing
that I believe many
new joiners in business
completely underestimate.
And this is how important
it is that your skill set
stays up to date.
That you keep on learning
and understanding
about new technologies as they emerge.
Because things are moving just so fast,
if you do not do that, you very quickly
will not understand anymore
what the new technologies are
and how you as a person and as a business
can benefit from them.
One technology that for sure in the past
sparked a lot of business
both from a personal
investment perspective
but also from business side is blockchain.
Many people were talking about blockchain
both in the context of
cryptocurrencies such as Bitcoin,
but also in the context of
serious business applications
that have the potential
to create and capture
significant value for shareholders
and other stakeholders of
business organizations.
So do you know what
blockchains actually are
and how they work on a
more technical level?
From my perspective, many
people talk about these things
but only very, very few really understand
how technologies such as
blockchain really work.
About a year ago I created a
course on blockchain technology
that covers the fundamentals,
both of blockchains
but also of other
cryptocurrencies such as Bitcoin.
If you're interested,
look in the description.
There you'll find a link to it
and also reviews from other students.
But I decided to give
just a significant portion
of that course here for you for free,
just that you can start learning
and building your understanding
of blockchain technology.
So this section that now follows
is an introductory section
where I give a basic intuition
into how blockchains work.
So if you always asked yourself
what this really is all about,
stay here and just keep learning.
We would like to start to discuss with you
what blockchains are
and why they are needed.
And let's begin with a simple
definition from Wikipedia.
What is a blockchain?
A blockchain is a continuously
growing list of records
called blocks which are linked and secured
using cryptography.
Let's go over the key
parts of this definition.
The blockchain is what
we are talking about
and it is a continuously
growing list of record.
So this means the individual
blocks of the blockchain
contain records, contain
some kind of transaction data
that are stored in individual blocks
and individual components of these blocks.
And these components,
these individual blocks
are linked together using cryptography.
So using some mechanisms
that secure these blocks
to each other and make sure
that they cannot be tampered with.
Let's have a bit more
visual representation
of what we just discussed.
This would be a very small
and simple blockchain
consisting of five blocks.
And the first thing that you're noticing
is that in every block, there
can be data secured into it.
This is this list of records
we just talked about.
So first, we start with the first block.
Then some kind of data is created,
some transactions are made,
and the first block is
filled up with data.
And once the first block is full,
then the second block is opened and again,
we write data into this
block until it is full.
And then we add a new block and so on.
And indeed, something like Bitcoin
works in a very similar way.
The block size, so the
size of individual blocks
in the Bitcoin cryptocurrency
is one megabyte.
So there is the case that after
every one megabyte of transaction data
a new block gets added to the blockchain.
And what you see here is
also that these blocks
are linked to each other.
There's a cryptographic
link between these blocks.
And the link that is used in Bitcoin
and most other blockchains
is something called a hash function.
And in the next lecture, we will discuss
in a bit more detail
what hash functions are,
how they are used, and why they help
to secure the blockchain
and make them tamper-proof,
prevent other people from changing data
in a way that should not happen.
So why are they needed?
Why do we even need
blockchain in the first place?
And probably you could
come up with a whole lot,
list of reasons, and one thing
that is very frequently
discussed in the literature
is a thing called the
double-spend problem.
So the problem that assets,
that cryptocurrencies could be spent twice
if you use them in some
kind of digital way.
And kind of the intuition of this problem
is just to think about Bitcoin
or any other cryptocurrency
as a file that you have on the PC.
So imagine you would have
some kind of file on your PC
and it says the owner of
this file owns one Bitcoin.
And the fact that you own this file
or have this file on your computer
kind of is proof that you
actually do own this one Bitcoin.
Now if you would like to
buy something with Bitcoin
or with whatever cryptocurrency
this is representing,
you would need to take this file
and send it to another person.
And now this other person
would have this file
and would kind of now be
able to show that the person
owns a certain amount of cryptocurrency.
So let's imagine person
A wants to transfer
cryptocurrency in the value
of 100 US dollar to person B.
Person A would send this file to person B.
Of course, what is the problem now?
It is inherent in the
nature of cryptographic
or kind of digital goods
that they can be copied.
If you have a file that
says the owner owns $100
or whatever cryptocurrency
you're talking about,
then you can easily just copy this file
and send it to another person this way.
So what can be done in
order to prevent person A
to send a certain amount of
cryptocurrency to one person
but then send the same amount
to another person as well?
And this problem is called
the double-spend problem
and it is the exact reason
why before Bitcoin invented
or kind of came up with
this blockchain concept,
it wasn't really possible
to have a decentralized
system of a cryptocurrency.
Before it always required
a centralized system,
something like a bank
that kept all the records
and was able to look into
all the different accounts
and was able to really see
whether the person was eligible
to transfer the same amount
of money again or not.
And blockchains can solve
the double-spend problem
because they provide a tamper-proof ledger
that is transparent and for
everybody open to check,
and kind of enables the
mechanisms that are in place
in order to prevent one person
to double-spending a certain
amount of cryptocurrency
or a certain amount of assets
with different types of other person.
And to bid on that, you can
come up with a whole lot
of very tangible and
very relevant advantages
that blockchains have over
more centralized ledgers
like the ledger that a bank would have.
And to go over them with you,
probably the most relevant ones, first,
blockchains are transparent.
At least most blockchains that
you hear about are public,
especially a blockchain like Bitcoin.
You can use a blockchain explorer
to look into every single block
that has ever been created
in the Bitcoin blockchain.
And you can look it up,
you can look at all the transaction data.
It's just there for you to see.
You can see which transactions
were going through
one bitcoin address in the past.
You can really look up
every single transaction
with the amounts of kind of coins
that were transferred
that exists out there.
Second, it is trustless.
Due to the nature of the blockchain,
it does not require any
centralized institution
that you need to trust
in order to be able to
participate in the system.
Even if you want to transact
values with the person
that you inherently do not trust,
you do not really want
to kind of be dependent
that this person fulfills
his word, keeps this word,
you can still use the blockchain.
Because the blockchain makes sure
that whatever agreement you came to,
whatever transaction you both filed
or whatever transaction you made,
this transaction actually will be executed
and the other person cannot
do anything to take it back.
Next, it is decentralized.
There is no such thing as
a centralized institution
that kind of can go to your accounts
and can just wipe your account,
take the money away from you
or maybe even change
the value of your money.
This is not possible because
of the decentralized nature
of most of blockchains like Bitcoin.
And finally, and of course
this is probably a summary
of all these other points, it is secure.
Due to kind of state of the
art cryptographic mechanisms
that are implemented into blockchains,
blockchains are believed
to be secure, and indeed,
the Bitcoin blockchain since
its inception since early 2009,
it was never hacked, not even once.
And kind of this is what I would say
a pretty strong argument
because I don't think
that there's any other computer system
that wasn't hacked for
such a long amount of time
which was kind of connected and live
and active on the Internet.
So blockchains can be very practical.
They have lots of use cases.
And we just discussed the
cryptocurrency use case
a minute ago.
And due to this practicality,
they have the potential to
disrupt entire industries.
And we will later have a section
that focuses on exactly this point
and builds on it and
discusses what use cases
there exist with blockchains
and how industries
can be affected by them.
Now, in the next lecture,
I will go into a bit more technical layer
and try to give you a technical intuition
of how blockchains work.
In this lecture, I would like to give you
a technical intuition
into how blockchains work.
For that, I will use this website,
it's anders.com/blockchain.
I did not create this website myself,
but it was created by Anders Brownworth,
so full credits for that to him.
You can check out his site
here, it's andersbrownworth.com
and also follow him here on social media.
And Anders also created these videos
which will cover lots of the things
that I will discuss now with you as well.
So feel free to check these out as well.
But let's get started.
So the fundamental building
block of blockchain
is something that is
called a hash function.
And here we see an example
of a hash function.
More precisely, this is a
hash function called SHA256.
SHA stands for Secure Hash Algorithm.
And what a hash function is
is that it takes an input,
and this is now the data here.
Currently it has nothing as an input,
and then it transforms
the input into an output.
And the output is a hash
function which is a string
of numbers and characters
that you see here.
So whenever I type something in here,
you see that the hash
function as an output changed.
And I can type whatever I want
and the hash function changed accordingly.
And interestingly enough is
if you now kind of delete this
and insert the very same thing,
the output will always be
the same based on the input.
So let's look at this,
it starts with F096,
so if I take this out, if we go back,
and once I insert the very same string
it will give me the same
output of the hash function.
And now I can type in this
input field whatever I like.
And I can type very long fields,
but the output of the hash function
will always be different
and it will always follow
the same format of having
the very same number
of character and numbers
in this output format.
And indeed I can copy whole books into it.
So this is the book,
"The Catcher in the Rye."
It consists of over 100
pages as you see here
and I can just copy this
text and insert it into here.
And you see it's lots and lots of text,
and it will give me a unique
hash function output out of it.
And as a matter of fact, if
I just change one character,
the whole hash function will change.
And it will change to
a very significant way,
it's basically you cannot
recognize it anymore
just by inserting one space
into the hash functions
as I'm doing right now.
So this is the hash function.
It transform an input into an output,
and you can be guaranteed that the output
always stays the same
given a certain input.
Now, let's take this understanding
of what a hash function is
and let's look into blocks.
And blocks are kind of the
main components of blockchains.
A blockchain are different blocks
concatenated with each other.
You will see this in a few minutes,
but let's start with one
individual block right now.
So this could be this block.
And a block typically
would have a block number.
It would have this thing, this nonce,
we will look into this in a moment,
and some kind of input field,
and then the hash function.
And what the hash
function does is it takes
all these things, the
number, the nonce, the data,
and then creates a hash
function which is the result
of a kind of all these
inputs taken together.
And now what we see if is,
if we change something here,
if we copy it and if we write something
into the data field, and of
course we can copy it a lot,
then the hash function changes.
Now, one key concept of
kind of a blockchain,
especially prominent in Bitcoin
but many others as well,
is the concept of mining.
And what mining is all about
is solving a certain cryptographic puzzle.
And the way this works in this example
is that here you see the nonce
field, and what we need to do
in order to successfully solve
this stylized cryptographic puzzle
is to change the nonce field in a way
that the hash function that
resides from that input
and from the other inputs
here starts with four zeros.
This is how this specific
example is set up.
Of course, if you look
into other blockchains,
this will be set up differently.
But here imagine we want to have something
that starts with four zeros.
Now, of course, I could
try to do that manually.
So I could start with one, but with a two,
now the hash function starts with a C.
I could give a three,
it starts with a five.
And I can try around a lot,
and I can try different characters,
but it's very difficult, right?
Because for me, it's
literally almost impossible
to guess what the nonce would be
that would turn the hash
function into a hash function
that starts with four zeros.
And this is now where the mining computers
or the mining mechanisms come into play.
And what that is it's basically a computer
or a kind of a mechanism
that just in a very short amount of time
tries lots and lots of
different combinations
until it has found a combination
which satisfies the requirement.
And in this case, the
requirement is that we need
a hash function that
starts with four zeros.
So let's try it now, let's click Mine,
and this will then do it
for us, we calculate a bit,
and now I found a nonce, the 4131.
And this nonce leads to a hash output
that starts with four zeros.
Now just take note that whenever
I just slightly change the nonce,
for instance instead of 4131
which gives us the four zeros,
I just write 4132 or maybe only 4130.
The four zeros go away.
In this case, actually
we're lucky we got one zero,
but of course, one zero isn't enough.
Let's here satisfy the requirement again.
And then of course, if I
change here this data field,
so another input field of the block,
if I just kind of very slightly change
and just insert an additional character,
the hash function is invalid as well.
And I would need to remine it
in order to get a nonce
combination which would work.
That might take some
time as you can see here.
Now it's looking for one
and now this is a new kind
of combination of a number
that will work here.
So this is what blocks are.
You need to kind of have some data inputs.
And of course, for instance
the data input here
could be transactions.
It could be something like the person A
transferred Bitcoin to person B.
And this would then the information
be that is stored in this block.
And it's secured by the hash function
because whenever I change something,
some data in the block,
then the hash function will become invalid
according to the certain
requirement that I define.
And I would need to
recalculate, to remine the block
in order to kind of make it valid again.
And this is exactly how
blockchains are secure.
And to understand that better,
let's look at another example,
now at a blockchain example.
And what this is is now a blockchain
consisting of different blocks.
And you can see that this
consists of exactly five blocks.
So how does this work now?
So let's start with the first block here.
You see that again we
have the block number,
we have this nonce field,
and we have the data field.
The data field is kind
of the body of the block
where then transaction
data could be inserted.
And now we have the previous
hash of the previous block.
And because this is just
the very first block,
it's just zero.
But then what we have is,
now this is the hash
for this specific block.
So what this hash does,
just as we have seen before,
is it takes all the
inputs here of this block.
So the block number, the nonce, the data,
and also this previous hash,
and just turns it into a new hash.
And now this block is
linked to the next block,
to the block number two
because this kind of output
hash of the whole block
is now this previous
hash of the next block.
So as you can see it's
exactly the same, 0001578.
It's just this very same hash.
And now again we have the data body
where we can just insert transactions
or any other information,
and now the hash of the block number two
is computated by taking all these inputs,
including the hash of the previous block,
and then calculating a new hash out of it.
And this way goes on and on, right?
So this hash, this output
hash of block number two
is now again an input
into block number three.
And then the output hash
of block number three
is calculated taking all the
inputs of block number three,
including the hash of the previous block.
And this goes on and on until here,
the currently last
block of the blockchain.
Now what happens if we
manipulate this blockchain,
if we kind of insert new data into it?
So let's write something
like, I'm a hacker.
So somebody now tried to change the data
of the information in this blockchain.
And what you see now is
that this block got unvalid
because now the new output hash
doesn't start with four zeros anymore.
So I need to mine it again in
order to make it valid again.
And as you see this
might take a few seconds.
And indeed, if you now kind of do this
with the Bitcoin blockchain,
there it's set up in a
way that mining a block
might take much longer
than only a few seconds.
It can take you minutes,
hours, maybe even days.
So just can take you as an individual
who wants to mine it a
significant amount of time
until to solve this cryptographic
puzzle that is defined.
But of course, now what is it
that really makes the blockchain secure?
And this is the ability of blockchains
to make it extremely difficult
to go back to the blockchain
and change something, some information,
which is buried deep down in here.
Because what happens if for instance
we change information into block three,
so a block that is kind
of a few blocks down
in the blockchain.
So now imagine I'm again a hacker
and I want to transfer
Thomas 10 coins to Anna.
Something like that.
So we want to steal coins from
Thomas and give them Anna.
The problem now is that not only
is the block three not valid anymore,
but all the blocks that follow
block three are invalid.
And why is that the case?
Because by changing the data
of this block number three,
we changed the output hash.
I mean, if you see here
again, if I do it once more,
if I just change one character,
this output hash function changes.
But then of course I do not
only need to remine this block,
but this output hash now is also the input
into the next block.
So the next block takes this hash function
of block number three
as part of the content
of the new block number four.
So if we change block number three,
the hash function of block
number four changes as well
because it takes the hash
function of number three,
block number three, the
previous block as an input.
And again, this output hash of block four
is again a data input for block five.
And then the output hash of
block five changes as well
because this hash changed.
So what you would need to do in order
not to manipulate the blockchain
is to remine all the individual blocks
starting from the first
that you manipulated.
So starting with number three.
And now we mine number four.
And now we mine number five.
So you literally need to
change the complete blockchain,
every single block since the block
that you manipulated in
order to make that happen,
in order to manipulate the blockchain
in a way that benefits you.
And of course,
cryptocurrencies like Bitcoin
make it extremely difficult for you
because as an individual,
it's just very difficult
to remine all these individual blocks.
And especially then also
having all these other nodes
having saved the former state
of the block within them.
It's almost impossible to do that.
So I hope this gives you
some kind of intuition
into how blockchains work.
Just to remind you again, this
was a stylized blockchain.
This is not Bitcoin itself
or this is not any other cryptocurrency
or any other specific
blockchain that you know.
This is just a stylized kind
of way how blockchains work.
But trust me that something like Bitcoin
works similar to this.
Thank you for watching.
If you took some value out of it,
please press the Like button.
And if you would like to
receive regular updates
and more video content, both on topics
around your success in the
first use of your career
but also updates on new
technologies such as blockchain,
push the Subscribe button
and you will be informed.
I'm planning on several
other content pieces
surrounding the topic of
blockchain in the future.
Thank you for watching
and have a good day.